[Música]
toda criança tem uma habilidade inata
aquela habilidade que já vem de fábrica
sabe alguma são muito criativas outras
já saem da barriga da mãe cantando e
dançando a minha como vocês podem ver
era comunicação o adorava me comunicar
não só no chuveiro ao telefone eu
gostava de falar por aqueles que não
tinham voz
então eu era líder de turma era a
primeira a apresentar o trabalho virei
presidente do grêmio na verdade eu
gostava era de treta
por causa disso eu escolhi fazer
comunicação social jornalismo o que eu
queria fazer justiça neste país de
desigualdade social algo dentro de mim
me falava que eu precisava gerar esse
impacto
mas mal sabia o que tinha pela frente
esperando porque eu sou geração
millenium meus amores
eu não queria um jornalzinho do bairro
não eu queria só a maior empresa de
comunicação do brasil eu queria impactar
em rede nacional a tv globo então saí de
vitória espírito santo sozinha e fui
morar em são paulo e com uma boa classe
média que quer pagar a faculdade eu fui
morar na periferia e pegava oito ônibus
de casa até o trabalho do trabalho até a
faculdade e depois voltava pra casa
foi muito corrido muito sofrido
trabalhei como telemática atendente de
telemarketing também trabalha como
vendedora de loja recepcionista de
clínica médica tudo que era honesto
depois de três anos esse perrengue
finalmente abriu o processo seletivo de
estágio da tv globo eu pude me
candidatar
foram disso foram dois meses mil é
18.226 candidatos 11 vagas primeiro e
único processo seletivo da minha vida e
opinião
mente estava entrando na tv globo
eu nunca imaginava que eu ia conseguir
mas eu realmente realizei aquele sonho e
tudo parecia que estava resolvido que eu
iria morrer lá dentro ele ia me
aposentar na globo
fui aprendendo bastante com a
experiência gostando de estar lá
trabalhando com vários famosos como a
fátima bernardes tive a oportunidade de
produzir o ronaldo fenômeno e também
conhecer a minha ídola claudia raia no
carnaval de são paulo
tudo isso num momento muito crítico do
brasil o país estava em crise mas o meu
facebook era cheio de likes é na minha
cidade eu era considerada a menina
prodígio com 21 anos já estava tão bem
sucedida na carreira e chegou o momento
de me formar
a única aluna da sala trabalhando com
alguma estabilidade na área mas sem
enxergar um propósito naquilo
sem sentir que eu estava realmente
transformando no brasil
mas como eu ia abrir mão de todo aquele
esforço que eu fiz como eu iria trocar o
meu status do linkedin para uma empresa
menor que a globo a questão de ego é
tudo isso abriu um buraco dentro de mim
e eu tentei tapar esse buraco de várias
formas vocês nem podem imaginar com
comida e exercícios até câimbra um
relacionamento tóxico e horas e horas a
noite trabalhando
nada resolveu mas eu tive que pedir
ajuda e de repente eu me vi na frente de
um psiquiatra que me deu um
comprimidinho branco
eu não estava entendendo que estava
acontecendo fui pra casa aceitei o
tratamento
dias depois eu comecei a me julgar
como assim tão jovem com futuro inteiro
pela frente privilegiada num lugar onde
todos querem estar com depressão eu não
tinha esse direito
fui pesquisar sobre o assunto e descobri
que muitos jovens da minha idade até
mais novos também recorriam aquele
comprimidinho branco
guardei assim
a informação que me deixou muito
inquieta e continuei trabalhando
belo dia tava passando pelo café e da tv
e vi uma moça
eu sabia que eu conheci ela de algum
lugar e me lembrei
ela era dona de uma ong cheguei toda
tímida porque eu não lembrava o nome
dela direito e falei oi
acho que o seu nome é sofia acho que
você tem uma ong que trabalha com jovens
e ela foi muito gentil me atendeu sim eu
sou sofia tem uma ong de jovens que eu
posso te ajudar e aí eu falei que eu
queria ajudar que eu tive a idéia de
compartilhar alguma coisa com esses
jovens do ar o meu tempo para quem
precisa porque talvez se eu olhasse para
o amador né do próximo a dor maior que a
minha
ficaria muito mais fácil de lidar com
aquele buraco e imediatamente a une
conector com a equipe da ong e ali eu
conhecia o instituto ser mais uma ong
que promove o desenvolvimento sócio
emocional e profissional de jovens em
situação de vulnerabilidade social
esse conceito é um pouquinho difícil de
explicar mas os jovens dos ser mais são
basicamente aqueles jovens que estão
próximos da linha da pobreza ou até
abaixo dela
são jovens que não têm acesso à educação
que não têm acesso à saúde cultura ou
que sofrem alguma situação de
vulnerabilidade mental e familiar
cheguei lá onde me apresentei me ofereci
para fazer qualquer trabalho ajudar na
limpeza na produção atender telefone
escreveu para o site estava à disposição
precisei passar por uma entrevista com a
coordenadora pedagógica gislene e ela
olhou pra mim e falou giovanna eu tenho
uma idéia se você der a aula e se você
compartilhar com os jovens como foi sair
de casa sozinha tem que amadurecer tão
rápido realizar o seu sonho eo pior né
frustrar com esse sonho compartilhe seus
aprendizados
eu não estava entendendo muito propósito
daquilo mas desafio é dado desafio
cumprido
fui lá e encarar uma turma de mais ou
menos 30 jovens na casa dos 15 anos
que me olhavam mais ou menos com essa
cara que vocês estão me olhando a id o
que essa garota vai ensinar pra gente eu
não sei dizer o que aconteceu naquele
dia eu sei que eu amei aquela forma de
me comunicar
e por incrível que pareça eles gostaram
e assim eu comecei a dar aula atrás de
aula dia após dia 900 alunos
o nosso relacionamento não acaba por aí
não eles me procuravam nas redes sociais
pediu ajuda para escrever um currículo
pediam ajuda pra participar de uma
entrevista de emprego e quando não sabia
responder ou conectava com alguém sabia
foi muito muito gratificante pra mim eu
fui me reconstruindo em algum momento
eles me sugeriram que criasse um canal
estava na moda todo mundo tava querendo
canal no youtube
e assim surgiu o minha limonada um canal
para falar sobre os meus aprendizados
positivos dos limões da vida um canal em
que compartilhavam um pouco daquilo que
eu acredito será algo positivo mas eu
sabia que também não era um caminho eu
sabia que o olho no olho ali na sala de
aula eu realmente conseguia transformar
as pessoas que aquilo era mais
importante do que impactar
superficialmente na internet mas o canal
continua lá e ele foi me empoderando
assim como esses jovens
eu sei eu sei poder aumento é a palavra
da moda até um pouco desgastada mas até
hoje eu não encontrei nenhuma palavra
que explica esse movimento interno de
você se conectar com você mesmo
encontrar uma força interior que te dá
coragem para enfrentar qualquer
adversidade
o mais louco de tudo é que eles foram
sem poder andar junto e foi o que
aconteceu com a kimberley ea natália
duas jovens que eu conheci lá no
instituto
num dia que ela estavam muito agitados
aquela turma que quer jogar a bolinha de
papel do professor sabe bem como é né eu
sabia que eu teria que dar a melhor aula
da minha vida para impactar aqueles
jovens aqui natália estavam no cantinho
assim de cabeça barra
cabeça baixa a nato sempre gosta de
lembrar desse dia falando eu só queria
dormir eu não queria ouvir ninguém
então eu me entreguei daí a melhor aula
que eu pude e meia hora estavam todos
rindo e se divertindo fazendo perguntas
e quando a aula acabou
as duas me procuraram me agradeceram e
pedir os meus contatos
naquele momento elas estavam me
conquistando como mentora e já
acompanhou as duas há dois anos e posso
falar me dão trabalho a quem sempre tem
muita dúvida quando o seu futuro
profissional será que continua naquela
oportunidade uma multinacional na área
de comunicação faz uma faculdade de
estética ou tento de voice se ela canta
lindamente e nós descobrimos juntas que
ela pode tentar tudo afinal ela é jovem
já natália me deu mais trabalho a nati
sempre quis ser jornalista então eu
incentivei ele entrou na faculdade
conseguimos um estágio pra ela
depois de um tempo algumas coisas
aconteceram ela teve que sair da
faculdade teve que trancar perdeu
estágio foi aí que eu interferir
o papel era lá vamos arrumar uma nova
oportunidade pra você
agora ela está trabalhando numa empresa
super legal que ela adora ea gente tem
um combinado ano que vem ela volta aos
estudos até aqui eu estava muito feliz
realizada em poderá dá mas eu sabia que
eu podia fazer mais
eu sabia que esse que eu que sei pão
pouco já conseguia compartilhar algo
ilegal com esses jovens
imagina quem sabe muito foi então que eu
tive uma ideia criar um evento para
levar palestrantes grandes profissionais
no mercado de trabalho para se conectar
com esses jovens falei com a sofia
lembra sofia fundadora do evento do
instituto ela topou e assim nascia a
conferência ser mais um evento
totalmente gratuito para jovens de 15 a
24 anos que passa uma manhã de sábado
debatendo temas como o futuro tecnologia
propósito autoconhecimento e outros
temas
que eles escolhem ano que vem 2019 nós
vamos para a quarta edição e já temos
basicamente 70 voluntários envolvidos 30
palestrantes que vão levar conteúdo de
forma gratuita 15 marcas apoiadoras e
quase três mil jovens impactados e eu tô
contando tudo isso pra vocês só pra
falar que como isso me transformou como
isso foi preenchendo o meu graco e eu
fui me encontrando não só como pessoa
mas também profissionalmente
hoje eu faço esse trabalho em outros
cantos do brasil e apoio ongs como plano
de menina gerando falcões eventos da ti
neide e também o estudo cacau show
além de são paulo e fazer alguns
trabalhos ali escolas públicas da
periferia como pirituba capão redondo e
brasilândia eu também atua em outros
estados tive a oportunidade de levar
aulas e conteúdos para o espírito santo
eo rio de janeiro bahia e no maranhão
isso mudou a minha vida numa direção que
eu não imaginava quando entrei na
faculdade quando que imaginar que eu
sairia de vitória espírito santo viria
para são paulo e depois de oito anos eu
estaria na periferia dando aula e também
é do convidada por empresas para
compartilhar conteúdos e dar
treinamentos que é o que eu faço hoje
consegui sair da tv consegui me
desvencilhar daquilo que estava me
fazendo mal
encontrei o meu propósito preenche o meu
buraco
a reflexão que eu deixo para vocês é que
todo mundo tem esse buraco como é que
você está preenchendo esse buraco de
forma superficial
depois do dia de hoje eu espero que não
obrigada
[Aplausos]